[Music]
Today, you're going to learn how to
design a beautiful and modern website
that truly resonates with your target
audience through a step-by-step
tutorial. I will show you how to take a
super simple brief and transform it into
this beautiful and modern homepage
design. And because our mission at UX
Peak is to help you become a UXUI design
pro, we've prepared the source file for
this tutorial that you can download for
free from the description below.
This is a step-by-step tutorial lesson
from our UXUI design mastery course,
which is a top design course packed with
many other amazing step-by-step
tutorials, strategies, resources, tips,
and tricks that you need to know about.
Use the link in the description or
simply search w.xpeak.com. uxpeak.com
and start your journey to become a true
UXUI design pro.
As a special bonus, use the exclusive
code pride 50 to get an incredible 50%
off your purchase. But act fast. It's a
timelmited offer for a few students
only. The best part is at the end of
completing the course, you'll receive
this shiny certificate of completion
with your name that you can share on
your LinkedIn or CV to show your
accomplishment. And stay tuned because
I'll also reveal the one feature that
every music company's homepage
desperately needs but often forgets.
Okay, are you ready? The brief for this
project is to create a landing page for
a fictional music streaming company
called Pride. Pride offers an ad-free
platform with millions of songs that is
web- based for now with the option to
pre-download the mobile version. The
target audience is young adults between
the ages of 16 and 26 who are into
dance, hiphop, rock, and R&B. The
purpose of the homepage is to convert
visitors into signups for the Pride and
Free platform. Before we dive into the
design process, it's important to
understand the problem you're trying to
solve and the people you're solving it
for. By researching your target
audience, you'll learn about their
needs, motivations, and frustrations,
which will inform your design decisions.
You can gather this information by
looking at current trends, competitor
websites, forums, groups, and reviews.
or even better by conducting user
research and speaking directly with
potential users.
Okay, let's start our process by
summarizing a few assumptions about the
target users that we will work with. Our
target users are both male and female.
They are 16 to 26 years old. They are
interested in dance, hiphop, rock, and
R&B music genres. The majority of our
users use desktop devices and are good
with technology. Now that we have our
assumptions clearly defined, we can
start formulating our design decision.
Everything we do from now on should be
with focus on our target audience and
the business objectives. We're now ready
to think about the color palette,
language, images, and content that we'll
use on our website to appeal to our
target audience. We want to make sure
that we convert them into customers.
For starters, we'll choose a bold and
beautiful dark theme with the primary
color of dark blue, which we'll use for
the background. We chose a dark theme
website because it's popular with our
target age group and is also easier on
the eyes during the evenings when our
users are most active. To add a pop of
energy and power, we select the primary
red color for all call to actions. We
can also add secondary colors of pink
and blue to bring personality,
uniqueness, and vibrancy to our brand.
If you want to use the same color
library template, you can find the link
to this template below the video. Now,
let's populate the template with all the
other colors that we're going to use on
our website. We chose our colors by
experimenting with different
combinations and making sure they were
easy to read and accessible.
Once you have your chosen colors, you
can define their use in the template
right in this area. We can also create
color styles which we've covered in the
previous module.
As a reminder, if you have all your
buttons red and you later decide to
change red to green, you can simply
change it in the color styles and the
color red will be replaced by green
everywhere you use the color style. As
you can see, once I change the color in
styles, the change was reflected in all
places
in our web design. We'll also need
transparent and gradient colors. So,
let's define those as well.
Okay, we now have all colors we are
going to use in the design. Let's create
color styles. To create a color style,
first select an object with your desired
color. Then click on the four dots next
to the fill option. A popup will appear
with several options. Click on the plus
icon and name your color.
Once you're done, click the create style
button and your style will be created.
Instead of a color code, you will now
see the name of your color.
To change a color style, select the
color and click on the edit style icon.
To adjust the color, click on the
colored square and make your changes.
The updates will be automatically saved.
If you need to detach a style for
individual edits, hover over the color
in the right panel and click the detach
style icon. This will allow you to
assign the element any color, but you
will no longer be using the style, and
any changes made to the text style will
not be reflected in the detached
version. Styles are most useful when the
same color is used in multiple places.
We will now create color styles for all
the other colors.
Great. Now that we have the color styles
ready, let's move on to the typography.
For a strong impact on our target
audience, we want to choose a font that
is big, bold, and clean. For this, enter
is the perfect option to make an even
bigger impression. We can use larger
text sizes. This typography style was
chosen to appeal to our specific target
audience, but it may not be appropriate
for other websites with different
audiences. Please note that these text
styles are designed for large desktop
displays. For smaller laptop screens,
tablets, and phones, different text
styles will be needed. Let's now set up
all the different font sizes and weights
we'll use for our website. For headings
and subheadings, we'll follow the
standard naming convention. When
defining your typography, you'll adjust
the font size, weight, and line height.
While letter spacing can also be
adjusted, it's not recommended for
beginners as it can sometimes have a
negative effect. For adjusting line
height, use percentage values instead of
set values. This way, as you scale up or
down, the line height will always be
proportional to your new size instead of
being fixed in pixels. For headings, aim
to have a line height between 110% and
130%, while for paragraph text, aim for
140% to 170%. Remember, the larger the
text, the smaller the line height should
be, and vice versa. For paragraphs,
we'll have three different sizes. An
optimal line height is around 150%,
which enhances the overall aesthetic.
We'll also include three UI label
styles: semi-bold, medium, and regular.
Similar to color styles, we'll create
text styles to make future updates
easier. If we ever need to modify the
text style, for example, if we decide to
change the font size from 22 to 16
pixels, we can simply update the text
style and have the changes reflected
across the entire website. To create a
text style, click on the four dots next
to the text, add a name, and then click
the create style button. We now need to
create text styles for all the other
headings, paragraphs, and UI labels.
Finally, let's find some images to use
in our design that will appeal to our
target audience. We'll obtain these
images from the premium paid image
library on invo.com with a license to
use them. To use these images in your
projects, you'll need to download them
from their website and obtain a license.
You can find the links to the images in
the Figma source file. Alternatively,
you can use similar free copyright free
images from websites like unsplash.com
or pixels.com.
It's important to only use copyright
free images or images you have the right
to use. Now that we have our colors,
typography, and images set up, we can
move to another part of this tutorial,
designing the website.
First off, we'll start by creating a
frame for our design. You can think of a
frame in Figma as an artboard and other
design tools. It's a container that
keeps all your elements in one place.
Let's make a frame that's 1920 x 1080
pixels.
Next, let's move on to the hero section.
Here, we're going to introduce Pride to
see how it looks on a 1920x 1080 pixel
screen resolution. We'll make a
duplicate. Then, let's take our main
frame and make it a bit larger. After
that, we're going to change the
background to our main black color and
add the logo, which is available in the
assets section below this video. Then,
it's time to add the navigation links.
We're going to use a UI label for these
links and select the style from our text
styles. You can duplicate the first link
to speed up the process. Just hold the
option key and shift on a Mac and drag
the object or use the keyboard shortcuts
command plus C and command plus V.
Now, let's change the link colors and
create a button for the signup link.
We're going to create an auto layout for
the signup link by pressing shift plus
A. Once we've done that, we will add a
fill, adjust the horizontal and vertical
padding, and add a 16 pixel corner
radius.
Now select the login link and the sign
up button and create another auto layout
with 24 pixels horizontal gap between
items. Now select all the other links
and create another auto layout with 48
pixels horizontal gap between items.
Finally, select the logo and the two
auto layout and create one more auto
layout with 386 pixels horizontal gap
between items. We're at a good point
now. So, let's add a grid. This will
help us make sure everything on the page
is aligned just right. Click on the plus
button to add a grid and then adjust it
by clicking on the grid icon. This will
bring up a popup where we'll change the
grid to columns. Set the count to four
and keep the stretch type. We'll add a
margin of 200 pixels and adjust the
gutter to 30 pixels. Next, let's return
to our navigation. Create an auto layout
and add a fill. We're going to add
transparent color styles for both the
fill and stroke.
Let's add some horizontal and vertical
padding and make sure our navigation
aligns with the grid.
Now set the corner radius to 24 pixels
and position the entire navigation 24
pixels from the top of the page.
Now we're ready to add a heading, some
paragraph text, and a call to action
button.
To speed things up, we'll style them
using the color and text styles we
created earlier.
Now we'll need to create another button
using auto layout. Set the horizontal
padding to 60 pixels and vertical
padding to 22 pixels. Add a fill of
select the primary red color. Lastly,
add a 16 pixel corner radius. While it's
usually a good idea to name your layers,
we're going to skip that in this
tutorial to keep things moving. Don't
worry, your template will come with
named layers. If you need help with
layer naming, there are plugins like
autoname and rename it that can help.
With our styles applied, let's align
everything together.
Next up, we'll generate a background
blur. Start by creating a rectangle and
changing its fill from solid to an
angular gradient.
We'll give it a slight rotation and
incorporate our secondary pink and blue
colors.
Feel free to experiment with the
position and opacity of these colors
until you strike the right balance.
Satisfied with the result? Great. Now
add a layer blur and set the value to
approximately 190. A little adjustment
might be needed.
Now we're ready to add our hero image.
We'll have to remove the background
first, which can be done using Photoshop
or a background removal tool like
Erase.bg.
With the background out of the way,
position the image just right.
Let's flip the image horizontally so our
title remains the focal point.
Now let's create a rectangle and add a
layer blur effect. This will make the
hero image fade away smoothly.
Now we'll position the title right in
the middle and make sure it's aligned
with the grid.
Time for a quick prototype review. Great
progress.
Let's focus on the second section of our
homepage, which will be focused on
displaying three amazing and trending
tracks of this week. Featuring the
week's top three trending tracks on our
homepage would boost engagement by
keeping content fresh, encouraging
exploration, and highlighting what's
popular, effectively attracting and
retaining visitors. Let's start with
creating the title for the second
section. We'll use the H2 text style
which is slightly smaller.
Now copy the paragraph from the previous
section and use dark gray color for the
paragraphs. This will give us better
contrast between the headings and the
paragraphs. Let's also change the
paragraph color in the hero section to
dark gray.
Now, select the title and the paragraph
and create an auto layout with a 32
pixel vertical gap between items.
Next, we'll need three images from our
image library.
We'll make them 300x 420 pixels, but we
might need to crop some of them. There
are a few ways to crop an image, but
we'll show you two simple methods. One
simple method is to hold down the
command key on a Mac and drag the image
with your mouse to crop it.
Another way is to doubleclick on the
image. Figma will add eight blue handles
around the image. You can then choose
how you want to crop the image by
clicking and dragging the blue handles
in any direction.
Great. Now that our images are the same
size, we can add a play icon from the
image library and position it at the top
of the image.
However, when you create an auto layout,
you'll see that you won't be able to
easily position the icon in the middle
anymore. Luckily, we can use absolute
positioning. Select an object you want
to place on top of another object and in
the right panel, select absolute
positioning. This will let you place the
object on top of another object and
align it as you like.
Now, we'll do the same with the rest.
Let's add more information. Now
we'll use H3 heading for the titles in
white color.
For the singer's name, we'll use a
medium paragraph with dark gray color.
For number of lessons, we'll use UI
label regular in gray color.
Now let's upload another icon for the
number of listens. Group the icon by
pressing command plusG and add an auto
layout. Add eight pixel padding from all
sides and a transparent background.
Lastly, apply a 25 pixel corner radius
and change the color of the icon.
We'll now need to create several auto
layouts and adjust the spacing between
layers.
In this last auto layout, we'll add
padding of 70 pixels from the top and
bottom and 60 pixels from the left and
right.
We'll also add a transparent background
color style and change the corner radius
to 24 pixels.
Finally, we'll add a transparent stroke
style and a background blur with a value
of 33.
All done. To make things easier, create
two copies and adjust the content
accordingly.
To copy an image, select the image,
press command plus C, and then select
the image you want to replace. Right
click on the image and click on paste to
replace. Do the same for the second
card.
We'll now adjust copy content for each
Great progress. Now let's connect all
three cards through auto layout and
select space between instead of packed.
This allows the spacing between the
cards to be dynamic based on the total
width. We'll adjust the width of the
auto layout so that it aligns with the
grid.
To make the layout a bit more
interesting, we can add some extra
bottom padding to the middle card to
make it stand out more. To apply only
bottom padding, click on the small icon
next to the padding option. You'll see a
controller to control padding from all
sides.
We'll also change the top alignment of
all cards to center alignment and add a
different background fill for the middle
card.
Next, we'll align our cards with the
copy and create an auto layout with an
80 pixel vertical gap between items.
Only one step left. Copy the background
blur from the hero section and adjust
the positioning colors until you find
the right balance.
Great job. We've completed another
section. Let's keep up the momentum and
continue to work together to complete
the remaining sections in the next
videos.
Welcome back. In this section, we're
going to focus on displaying a variety
of music genres on our website to appeal
to our target audience.
Our goal is to design an option for
users to start listening to these
libraries. In order to accomplish this,
we will design a carousel that includes
arrows, allowing users to browse through
additional libraries.
To start, let's copy our existing title
and paragraph.
Now change the alignment and the copy.
And don't forget to make sure that the
frame is aligned with the grid.
Next, grab the arrow icon from the image
library and create an ellipse that has a
height and width of 55 pixels.
Remove the fill and add a dark gray
stroke with 2.2 pixel width.
Create an auto layout and use absolute
positioning to place the arrow icon in
the center of the ellipse. Perfect.
Now, duplicate the entire arrow and
rotate it like so.
Now, select the two arrows and add an
auto layout with 24 pixel spacing
between.
Adjust the color of the arrows so it's
clear that only one of the arrows is
currently clickable.
Now select everything in this section
and create an auto layout with the space
between property.
Next, we'll add images to our carousel.
We'll grab four images from our library
and adjust their size to 358x490
pixels.
If you come across any odd sizes like
490.48,
don't worry, you can fix it by simply
dragging the frame up and down by one
pixel. You can also adjust the nudge
amount in the settings for even more
control.
I feel
you.
We will create four frames for our
content by right-clicking on the image
and selecting frame selection. Within
each of these frames, we will include a
library heading and the number of songs
in each library. We will copy the
existing text, change it, and then apply
our text styles.
We'll add a music icon to support our
copy and align everything together.
For the bottom part, we'll add a nice
background blur to make the text on the
image more accessible and readable.
We'll change the frames property to clip
content to keep everything neatly inside
the frame.
We'll use a color from the image to
match it nicely and add a layer blur
with adjusted opacity.
Next, we'll add the play button and
position it slightly above the center.
We'll align it with the rest of the
content and then copy it over to the
other frames.
Then we'll just easily change the
content for each frame.
We will copy the background blur and
adjust the color for each frame
individually.
Next, we will select all cards and
create an auto layout with the property
space between. This will nicely help us
to make sure that everything is evenly
spaced.
Then, select the last three cards and
add a 24 pixel corner radius. Now it's
time to create a beautiful shadow
reflection.
To do this, we will create a copy of the
image and position it slightly below the
image. We will apply blur with the value
of 49.
Then we will create an auto layout
between the shadow and frame.
We can do the same for the rest of the
images.
Heat. Heat.
We'll adjust the opacity until they have
the same luminosity.
Finally, we'll put everything together
with the top part. Let's preview the
design and see what progress we've made.
Great job. That is looking great. We've
just finished another section.
Awesome. Let's step into our next
exciting section, which we will call
trending artists. This part is all about
shining a light on the artists that
everyone's buzzing about and their top
tracks that are keeping our platform
lively and exciting. Think of it as our
way of showing just how vibrant and
energetic Pride is all through the eyes
and ears of our community.
We're going to keep things friendly and
straightforward using language that
speaks directly to our users. We'll wrap
our words in a design that feels like
part of the family, consistent with
everything else they've seen from us.
Let's pick out the five cool artist
images from our library.
But we're not stopping there. We're
giving them a little makeover. Rounding
those corners to transform them into
perfect circles. We'll resize each image
to 200x 200 pixels, making them just the
right size.
And let's add a sprinkle of our magic.
Alongside each artist name, we'll
include the number of tracks and a
special feature link. Think of it as a
warm invitation, a gentle nudge for our
users to explore deeper and maybe even
encourage them to join our community.
We'll start by setting up an auto
layout. This is our first step toward
organizing our content beautifully.
Let's apply our text and color styles to
create an effective visual hierarchy.
We'll use a slightly larger size for the
artist names as that's the most
important information. For the number of
songs, we'll use our gray color since
this information is less critical. And
we'll make the explore button slightly
more prominent to encourage exploration
of those artists.
We'll ensure there's enough room for
everything to breathe by adding 32
pixels of horizontal padding and 40
pixels of vertical padding.
We're setting the stage for our design
elements to shine. Next, we're going for
that sleek and modern vibe with a
transparent background fill and stroke
style.
Now, for the artist photo, this is where
we want to draw the eye. We can add a
shadow effect to give it some depth,
making it stand out more. We can use the
color picker tool to copy a color
directly from the photo.
We'll tweak the shadow values to ensure
it's noticeable without overwhelming the
photo. Now, let's preview it properly
and see whether we need to tweak
something.
Let's duplicate this card and change the
photos and the contents.
And here's a neat trick. We'll copy the
background blur layer from the second
section and adjust it until it matches
our design beautifully.
Finally, it's time to preview our
design. Fantastic. We're making a great
progress. Now, let's lock the layer to
keep our design tidy. Simply click on
the lock icon next to the layer name in
the layers panel. This will ensure
everything stays in place as we work on
other parts of our design. Next, we're
going to bring all our cards together in
harmony. Select them all and create an
auto layout with the space between
property. This keeps our cards neatly
aligned and ensures they're in perfect
sync with the grid.
Now, let's sprinkle a bit of creativity
into our layout. By creating an auto
layout for the second and fourth card
and applying an 80 pixel top pattern,
we're adding a dynamic rhythm to our
design. It's like we're playing with the
visual flow, making the layout more
engaging and unique.
That looks so much better, doesn't it?
The next step is to select the entire
section except for the background blur
and create another auto layout. This
time, we're going with 80 pixel spacing.
It's all about giving our elements room
to breathe and ensuring that our design
feels open and inviting. If you had
locked the background layer earlier,
now's the time to unlock it. Just right
click on the background blur area, which
will highlight the layer in the layers
panel. Click on the lock icon again to
unlock it. And then you can adjust the
layer's position as needed.
Finally, let's add a finishing touch, a
button at the end of this section. This
button is a call to action for users to
explore all the artists on the platform.
We can easily copy the button from the
first section of our page and update the
text. The copy will be dynamic, meaning
it will show exactly how many artists we
have currently on the platform.
Incorporating a see all artists and the
number of artists button significantly
enhances user experience by introducing
transparency and setting clear
expectations.
This method not only informs users of
the breadth of content available,
fostering a sense of abundance and
choice, but also utilizes psychological
triggers, encouraging users to explore
further. By quantifying the options, it
directly taps into users curiosity,
motivating them to click through and
engage with more content. This approach
can lead to increased time spent on the
platform, deeper engagement, and higher
conversion rates as users feel more
informed and in control of their
browsing experience. And just like that,
we've wrapped up yet another beautiful
section of our web design. Great job.
We're moving on to an exciting part
where we'll spotlight one of the current
popular artists on the Pride platform
and showcase their hit songs. Let's jump
right in. We are going to spotlight an
artist called Arya. She will be the face
of this platform as we've already used
her in our hero section. In the real
world, this would be a popular artist
that people love. First, let's grab
Arya's picture from our image library.
We want Arya to really stand out, so
we're going to remove the background
from her picture.
As I've mentioned before, there are
fantastic tools out there like erase.bg,
remove.bg, or Adobe Express that can
help you do this effortlessly and for
free.
Next up, we'll reuse the title and
paragraph layout from the previous
section, but tweak the text to introduce
Arya.
We'll apply our styles we defined
earlier. We'll share some interesting
tidbits about her and emphasize that
she's an exclusive artist on the Pride
platform. This is our chance to make
area's introduction as engaging as
possible.
Are
Now, let's create a spotlight for Arya's
most loved song. We'll design each song
as a mini feature complete with a cover
title, artist name, and how long the
song plays.
Heat.
Okay, we got the song titles and artist
names ready. Now we can arrange them
using an auto layout with a cozy 8 pixel
spacing. This keeps everything neat and
clean. For the song covers, we'll select
seven images from our library. The first
image needs to be square, so let's crop
it accordingly.
By framing this cropped image and
duplicating the frame, we can
efficiently manage the other images
without having to crop each one
individually.
Just slide the second image into the new
frame, adjust, and then remove the
original.
Repeat this for the rest and resize each
image to a crisp 80x 80 pixels.
We will also nicely round the corners of
each image to make it nicely modern and
friendly. Now take the first song image
and details we've prepared and arrange
them into an auto layout, tweaking
alignment and spacing until it's just
perfect. We can then borrow the play
button from a previous section, scale it
down to fit our design.
and add the song duration with a
comfortable 24 pixel spacing between
elements.
Let's create another auto layout for all
of these elements, setting the spacing
to space between.
We'll duplicate this frame for each of
the six songs, updating the covers and
details accordingly.
We
We'll use auto layout to make sure each
card has equal spacing. creating a
visually appealing grid. For the
finishing touches, we'll select all the
elements within the card and wrap them
in another auto layout. This time with
40 pixel spacing and generous padding of
40 pixels on the sides and 60 pixels on
the top and bottom.
We'll apply a transparent background and
stroke style for a sleek look.
Then we'll soften the edges with a 24
pixel corner radius. We'll add a
background blur effect with a 48 value
to achieve that trendy glassy effect.
We'll align everything nicely and wrap
the entire composition in an auto
layout.
Now, for a bit of flare, let's
experiment with a gradient background
blur. This might take a few tries, but
it's all about finding that perfect
blend that makes our design pop. If
something doesn't quite look right,
we're free to tweak until it's
absolutely perfect.
Let's take a moment to preview our work.
And would you look at that? It has
turned out amazing. Fantastic effort.
That is looking good.
Moving forward in our Figma tutorial,
we're tackling an essential feature for
any website, the sign up section for the
newsletter. In this next step, we'll
incorporate a newsletter signup form
right on the homepage, ensuring it's a
breeze for visitors to subscribe to the
company's updates. We'll kick things off
with a catchy title, don't miss a beat,
paired with a compelling description
that outlines the benefits of
subscribing. Writing compelling UI
design copy for your website. Including
newsletter banner is crucial for
boosting conversions on your website.
It's not just about informing visitors.
It's about engaging them, sparking
interest, and making the action of
signing up irresistible. Good copy
highlights the value they'll receive by
subscribing. This clarity and appeal can
significantly increase the likelihood of
visitors taking action directly
impacting your website's conversion
rates. Keep it concise, clear, and
focused on the benefits to the user, and
you'll see more visitors turning into
subscribers. To organize the title and
the description, we will create an auto
layout with the spacing between them of
32 pixels. We will adjust the horizontal
resizing properties of the title and
paragraph to fill container. The entire
frame will be set to 618 pixels wide to
align perfectly with the grid.
Next, we'll select the headphone image
from our library, positioning it to the
right side of our text. By removing any
unnecessary elements from the image, we
will make the image stand out more with
a transparent background. Ensuring the
image maintains its original charm,
we'll lock the aspect ratio by selecting
the constraint proportions icon. Then,
we will adjust its width to 576 pixels.
Directly below our enticing text, we'll
introduce an email field for visitors to
input their addresses.
The subscribe button will come next. We
will design it by using the send icon
from our image library and borrowing the
background design for the play button.
We will simply replace the play icon
with the send icon.
To bring it all together, we will create
an auto layout between the email field
and the subscribe button, setting the
spacing to 24 pixels. Then, grouping
both together, we'll create a new auto
layout with a 56 pixel gap. Adding one
more layer of auto layout, we'll add
horizontal padding of 138 pixels and
vertical padding of 40 pixels.
After adding a fill and adding the image
into our auto layout, we'll shift the
direction to horizontal and arrange the
components as needed.
We will transition the background's
color from solid to linear, which create
a subtle fade effect, enhancing the
aesthetic appeal. We'll round off the
corners of the main frame to 32 pixels
to maintain consistency with the overall
design style we have been using
throughout the website. We'll adjust the
spacing property to space between, which
will allow us to fine-tune the frame
width. This will help us to fit our
frame to the grid precisely. For an
intriguing visual touch, we want the
image to slightly exceed the bounds of
its container achieved through absolute
positioning and modifying the frame
properties.
Now we will work on the positioning and
spacing until we get it just right.
As we approach the final section of our
homepage, the footer, we're setting the
stage for convenient navigation for
website visitors. Starting with copying
the logo and sign up button from the
navigation bar. We'll divide the footer
into three column
get started account and pride. Each
column will be labeled using the text
style UI label with titles in a darker
shade of gray and list items in a
lighter shade to enhance visibility and
clickability.
I will now add quickly a few links to
different pages of the Pride website.
We will use auto layout to bring
everything nicely together and space
elements appropriately.
For the next portion, we'll add a brief
description of Pride and links to social
media, followed by a line divider.
The last section of the footer will
feature copyright information, links to
privacy related content, and crucial
legal details.
all aligned and spaced correctly.
Next up, we'll use an auto layout
between the second and last sections of
the footer. This will help us keep
everything neatly organized and aligned.
To ensure a cohesive look, we'll adjust
the line divider, making it slightly
shorter so that it matches the width of
the last section perfectly. This small
detail adds to the overall polish and
professionalism of our design. Before we
finalize everything, we'll ensure the
homepage sections are spaced adequately,
making any necessary adjustments for
perfect alignment.
To wrap up, a background blur will be
applied to our navigation for a sleek
finish.
Now, let's take a moment to preview our
final design. Take a step back and
admire the incredible work we've done
together if you have been following
along. Fantastic job. Through this
tutorial, you've gained valuable
knowledge and skills to design visually
appealing homepage designs confidently.
If you've been following along or are
feeling inspired to give it a go
yourself, now's your chance to create
something similar or even better. Below
you'll find a link where you can submit
your creation. We're eager to see what
you've come up with. I hope you enjoyed
this video tutorial as much as I did. I
will see you in the next one.